by the way he's also going to be showing
off his hoop skills he goes from
dodgeball to the hard court I love that
he's taking part in the celebrity
basketball classic tomorrow yes that
game is over at UNLV Floyd Mayweather
does one of the big names behind the
event which does include a red carpet
for all the stars our Lauren negretti
joining us now from the TNN this morning
hi Lauren are you still working on your
hoop skills
yeah we improved a little bit let the
record show I did make it when the
camera wasn't rolling I swear but yes
that's right good morning guys good
morning folks yeah we are here live at
the Cox Pavilion where it will be those
players like you said all across the
board star-sided event a lot of uh
former and current NBA and NFL players
including some digital creators just
like the guys I've got here hey guys
[Applause]
okay roll call you know Bo amarito
Jackie Moon AKA him in the North
Tommy Moulton edmonix AKA daddy long
range and we got Blake behind the camera
over there so guys big game to going on
tomorrow wave hey Blake big game
tomorrow how does it feel to be involved
you know it's crazy it's surreal at this
point we're really trying to take it all
in but at the same time hey these cats
don't want that smoke Floyd Mayweather
Stefan Diggs they never seen Jackie Moon
never seen edmonic study long range I
don't think so all right talking to Big
Talk there I hope you can follow it up
no kidding for sure for sure yeah no it
is a surreal moment you know just two
years ago before we had the channel we
looked up to these guys I mean still do
today so it's going to be awesome to be
able to get on the court with them throw
the ball around a little bit no that's
awesome and you guys all got started
kind of a coveted pivot here with your
because your millions of subscribers
there a thousand subscribers yeah
exactly so it started at the height of
coven we're just a big friend group that
always thought we're entertaining
looking for something to do and this is
the perfect time you know why not start
a YouTube channel see where it goes and
we really never look back from there and
it's cool to see the entire city of St
Louis support us but then even Way
Beyond that in the entire country and
now that hopefully the world going to
keep spreading our message and you know
keep putting not great content for
everybody definitely welcome to show
them a preview real quick there okay get
ready for it get to it
this is the best facet of my game Go For
It Go for
it
well you're gonna see plays like that
happening tomorrow again doors open
three o'clock tickets available online
we've got that link for you on our
website 8newsnow.com for now Lauren
negretti at the Cox civilian thank you
what's the underhanded throw that's
their skills I'm like the cartwheel that
was the best
shots
all over the court is going to fire
underhanded shots from like from the
three-point line if it goes in hey
that's true thanks Lauren appreciate it
that's good they said bring your skills
they didn't say what kind of skill right
whatever they can do their YouTube looks
awesome I don't have to we'll have to
follow this all right the guys Doug guys
all right